I don't misspell references police
website is www.hs was calm and your name
Alex Ferrari Tyson and I really really
wanted to try to bring all my loves
together of like dirty underground kind
of stuff with action a very strong
female character kicks ass so you'd save
it for me my wife was saving for a while
and everybody didn't get paid a lot once
it's like food
that's our next front and how are you
promoting the belt the one thing we're
doing is we are knowledge and the scenes
posters
we'll see and what are your expectations
with the film get the meat that get the
feature made that's the goal of this I
love the red carpet as much as I want
for sure I think it's a feature made and
that's the goal I was gonna wear shorts